[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre la efectividad de las
vacunas cuando hay cuando hay inmunidad
y el riesgo entre la primera y la
segunda dosis para comer conversar sobre
este tema nos acompaña el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y
asesor científico de france 24 gracias
por estar con nosotros desde finales de
diciembre comenzó la campaña de
vacunación más grande de la historia
seis meses después cuál es el balance de
la eficacia de las vacunas contra el coi
19 protegen contra la enfermedad contra
una hospitalización y contra la muerte
por el virus
hay tres cosas fundamentales que nos ha
enseñado la vacunación hasta ahora hay
por lo menos 2500 millones de personas
vacunadas lo primero las vacunas son
seguras es mucho más el beneficio y no
producen en un efecto dañino que se haya
documentado en un número importante de
población aunque no son inocuos lo
segundo es que la cobertura vacunal
evita las complicaciones y la muerte que
se puede llevar de las complicaciones
por lakovic 19 y lo tercero es que sigue
siendo efectiva a pesar de variantes
virales aunque las respuestas son
visibles entre los grupos de vacunas
pero en conclusión son vacunas seguras y
efectivas
justamente usted lo estaba mencionando
hace un momento y es que han aparecido
nuevas variantes que tan efectivas son
las vacunas para prevenir la muerte y el
contagio de esas mutaciones
las variantes que se llaman de interés o
variantes que pueden tener alguna
peligrosidad
en la mayoría de las vacunas son
cubiertas efectivamente hay algunas que
no por ejemplo la vacuna de astrazéneca
con la variante beta o la sudafricana o
algunas vacunas no son efectivas como se
esperaba con las variantes como la del
reino unido sin embargo la eficacia se
pierde en muy poca proporción y
determina y es determinante seguir la
vacunación que es la única forma de
evitar que haya nuevas variantes en
conclusión las vacunas son seguras para
las variantes aunque tienen variaciones
significativas en algunas de ellas
doctor cuando se puede hablar de
inmunidad y como si el comportamiento en
países de américa latina donde los des
confinamientos ya están a la orden del
día por ejemplo el caso de colombia
si en colombia se está haciendo algo
paradójico que es abrir la economía en
el mayor pico y cuando la tasa de
vacunación de segundas dosis no va más
allá del 5 ó 6 por ciento de la
población vamos a ver cómo termina esto
pero definitivamente la vacunación se
acompaña de la desaceleración de los
casos para llegar a la inmunidad de
rebaño no quiere decir que no se vaya a
llegar al mundial rebaño pero lo vamos a
llegar por la vía de mayor número de
infectados y no de mayor número de
vacunados se va a lograr la inmunidad y
esperamos que eso suceda pronto pero
ojalá que sea la vacunación y no la
infección las responsables y mundial de
la riva no cuáles son los riesgos tanto
de contagio como de muerte para las
personas entre la primera y la segunda
dosis
es un punto muy importante porque una
dosis él protege pero no es suficiente
se necesita tener dos dosis y al menos
la segunda semana de la segunda dosis es
donde hay la inmunidad lo que hemos
visto en los casos es que la mayoría ha
sido entre el periodo de vacunas que las
personas se infectan y se atribuyen a
fracaso de la vacuna no las vacunas son
altamente efectivas pero entre los
momentos de la vacunación puede haber
infección la eficacia de las vacunas
contra el jove 19 se podría comparar con
la eficacia de vacunas para otras
enfermedades como el sarampión la polio
la varicela
estas vacunas son estamos aprendiendo
realmente todavía tenemos información
que se está construyendo no tenemos una
información definitiva lo que se sabe es
que no son 100% efectivas y como ninguna
unas cien por ciento pero son seguras
altamente eficaces y protegen sobre la
tanto en la mortalidad como en el
ingreso a cuidado intensivo por eso es
llamado es a vacunarse con tranquilidad
con seguridad y recuerden que hoy
vacunarse es un privilegio y debemos
hacerlo con disciplina con amor en la
ciencia y con decisión pues doctor
carlos eduardo pérez como usted lo ha
dicho vacunarse y amor a la ciencia a
usted muchas gracias por este análisis
por la ampliación y a ustedes gracias
por su sintonía continúen con nosotros
en france 24
[Música]